in Harry Dunn's memory a pavilion will
be rebuilt it's a welcome distraction
from his family's legal fight he meant
so much to us he meant so much to the
whole family
Harry was killed in a collision with
American answer coolest last August
after she left RAF croton in
Northamptonshire
she claimed diplomatic immunity and left
the UK and was later charged with
causing his death by dangerous driving
Harry's family claimed the Foreign
Office allowed her to go under launching
a private criminal prosecution against
the foreign secretary Dominic Crabb we
need this for everybody to know how the
decisions were made and why they were
not followed the procedure that
guidelines they should have done and for
me to get some sort of on September the
14th a Foreign Office official texted a
US official to say I think that now the
decision has been taken not to waive
immunity there's not much mileage in as
asking you to keep the family here
it's obviously not as approving of their
departure but I think you should feel
able to put them on the next flight out
Harry's family claimed that an sakulos
left the next day there's a very clear
rule that it's for the police to
establish who has immunity that rule was
broken and it constitutes we allege a
very serious instance of misconduct in
public office a spokesperson said the
foreign secretary and Prime Minister
have been clear with the u.s. that the
refusal to extradite answer Kulas
amounts to a denial of justice and she
should return
one legal commentator says it's unusual
to bring a prosecution against a
government minister the courts have said
that's a high threshold even the other
summons issued is presumably even harder
to prove it and no doubt mr. robb will
defend it and say that this is an abuse
of the courts process and not something
that the courts should be involved in in
Harry's case the Foreign Office is
confident that they acted properly and
lawfully throughout but his family
believed this needs to be tested in the
courts lissa down sky news
Northamptonshire